ladies and gentlemen welcome to Monday
melee thank you for joining us happy
Monday which is always better Oskie
Jason I'm Ally creeper in the corner I
nailed it
today we're gonna be playing
transformers devastation that's right I
love giant robots
I love smashing things and this combines
to my favorite things yeah if it
embarrassing that's more a night to look
up with the difference between an
Autobot and uh that is embarrassing
don't ever say that again in my presence
I'm furious
good lord are you could change into any
any kind of vehicle what would it be
think about it don't answer right now
all right ah Canadians eat cp3 wanna get
to see you tear me sis what's going on
Squasher oh it's copening opening Monday
with a lot of little emoticons wrecked
upon rising seven I don't know what I
got the touch means I hope that's not an
STD reference and we're gonna start from
the beginning
now I brother Todd Autobots and the
other one's perfect yeah what's up bad
girls gaming today more Transformers
puns Oh get ready get ready
I'm a bevy of points I'm a bevy of funds
one thing I do like about this game
Ralph about is I joined the cell shading
animation situation I think not a lot of
games have that I think like crackdown
had it and o-over star not big good god
you know all I'm gonna say is I feel
like if you're a giant robot you don't
also need to have tentacles it feels
like trying too hard yeah you're already
a cute like Galactus did it right
he's not Galactus wasn't a robot but he
just kind of showed up and like stomped
around and tried to eat our planet right
from the Chi it's a comic book character
silver surfers and I mean if I Fantastic
Four don't worry about I know I'm not
talking to any nerds right now so no
one's gonna get that reference there we
go we exactly ooh
brother taught old-school station wagon
hype you know what I gotta say right off
the bat that is what I would turn into
one of those woody station way there we
go quick fun factoid about Transformers
the movie Orson Welles first movie
Citizen Kane his last movie Transformers
the movie hears the voice of Unicron the
giant planet sized robot which by the
way if it's a planet sized robot I think
it's just a robot planet and not a robot
yeah you know that goes under the
category of planets not robots I think
there's just a bunch of robots walking
around the city in no one cares more and
more people are like oh yeah there's
like crazy yeah Jimmy's very doctor who
doesn't I do it's like oh yeah well the
incident to be fair though that's how
New Yorkers treat everybody yeah like
when your New York there's like hey
what's up hey
Oh Starscream hi Starscream was which
ones Starscream he's the he turned into
the f15 or f-14 right all rising seven
says Galactus is perceived differently
by different species so if he attacked
Cybertron or that I can't read the rest
of that it's going too fast but I think
that's true that's a good point
robot dwarf planet I don't know if that
exists I think that would be a moon
right just like a robot moon
what did you want to know that also I've
always questioned how Optimus Prime can
speak because he doesn't have a mouth
[Music]
it's just like a metal plate over his
face and it doesn't even set it's not
even a speaker it doesn't have holes in
it see what I'm saying he has no lips or
anything or at least you can hear it
from Earth but I guess that isn't too
scary oh this game is great look at this
oh I have a giant laser axe you know how
much I love lasers and axes how aliance
is I would not ignore Chris Hemsworth
flying over my city I mean to be fair
we've met yes he's from oh my god
anybody that you only have to be from
Boston to be to reside in Beth's heart
but met the Hemsworth brothers they are
the most good-looking two people on like
your date here's the you were brought
you're you're better than the rest of us
you're definitely a movie star and super
nice by the way I think what are they
like Australian or English or something
actually alright super nice chance
Zacharias says the FaceCam moved to the
upper upper right at the perfect moment
so well done Jason O'Malley finally he's
done something right for the first time
captain Kaiser says sex with the
transform and be like sex with the
toaster oh but a sexy toaster like one
of those like like good-looking toasters
that you get at Target that don't really
cook your food that well right oh yes
that's my special vehicle attack when it
turns blue how taller that that's a good
question
look I mean if this game is to scale
which I guess why wouldn't it be
they're both 6-3 oh we're talking about
the Hemsworth brothers see I went right
back to transformers
I thought you were talking about
transformers I was like I don't know
they look about 10 feet tall hazard
brothers are talking it's weird though
if you look at if you watch cabin in the
woods great movie by Chris Hemsworth not
is ripped in that movie and he looks a
lot younger cuz it was done before it
was done before all the Avengers but
they put it out half yeah cuz I guess it
got shelved and then cuz Joss Whedon
like I think wrote either wrote and
directed cabin in the woods or just
wrote and and then then when the trip
when the Avengers were such a huge movie
they're like what else do we have with
Joss Whedon supposed to put out but yeah
he doesn't look ripped at all which is
hilarious it really looks like her
something still is acting at some point
Rosie says TMNT and the style should be
sweet I agree I love this the shading
oh is that true I love this style of I
love that it says I loved animation but
it just looks it has that sweet
yeah cabin in the woods spring fart a
great great name by the way
cabin of the woods is an amazing movie
also if you've seen it no spoilers in
the chat don't be a jerk don't be a jerk
about it
doom shine I know I always get a boner
in the home appliances section at Target
ooh what do you think you're most
attracted to there's a lot of home
appliances in there I've always thought
dishwashers are sexy just because it's
doing I just get aroused by the fact I
don't have to wash dishes by
practicality I get a rose by
practicality plus it makes kind of like
a sexy rhythmic noise doesn't it like
plus it's well-built saying I appreciate
well-built I appreciate a well-built
appliance if we're going for how to get
to my heart through appliances YouTube
asked when who the first video game I
ever played great question I used to
have an Odyssey this is gonna date me
but I just turned 38 last week so
there's things I dated myself but an
odyssey was something before the Atari
2600 wheter was my first thing at
commodore 64c was the Odyssey actually
think I might've been a Commodore 64 no
I'm thinking about it and that was
instead of a disk drive they had a tape
player that played cassettes that's true
that's a true thing played cassettes and
it took like an hour to load I remember
I had this game Robin Hood on cassette
and so it would load up Robin Hood would
take 45 minutes and then you would get
three lives and then the guy with the
flaming arrow would always kill me and
then I'd have to start over again and it
was horrifying that's the thing you know
I hate to go into kids today rant kids
today you guys got it easy man you just
everything just loaded I remember
waiting even like in 2002 waiting like
10 minutes for seems to look like was
still a thing that was happen yeah
now people are upset because Oh an
update of three gigs takes whatever but
you know what I guess you know what I
guess it's same old same old now instead
of a cassette that takes an hour it's
like an update to fix a patch after you
buy your right so I guess you know what
you kids today I've experienced the same
frustrations we all do hey here's a
dinosaur robot knob that is the
definition of trying to run what the
hell really dodgy singer won all right
kids to LK PD says we're not all kids
here aren't we all kids at heart though
guys come on give yourself some credit
there we go I do like it when you're
playing a character and he's talking to
himself but tells you what to do yeah
like in The Witcher like that's in The
Witcher 3 that's when he was constantly
saying it's like I've got to get more of
this potion it's like pre talking to bro
success yeah I can do my god oh is that
true they talk to themselves dead what
suppose man very Shakespearean success
which time
watching the stream and coffee job in
the working that's like kind of great by
the way so kind of great props for
watching a coffee make sure everyone can
see watch yeah get yourself a coffee and
charge it to this Chuck charge it to us
Gingrich says I'm two weeks older than
you blade but I killed still consider us
kids me too but you know what that
doesn't mean we can go into McDonald's
Playland without weird looks just cuz
it's up here doesn't mean it's down here
Witcher is good pyromania yeah I agree
and one game of the year which are one
ah what is this thing perhaps all game
characters are schizophrenic maybe we
should get now we just spiral it to a
deep discussion about game characters
mental states yeah who's the most
well-adjusted the most mentally healthy
game character that's what I wanted to
tell you right now come on dude
could be Optimus speaking of pretty guys
Ryan Reynolds be still my heart
hey see you got AC from Boston Beth let
me check with our boss our Wikipedia
Boston chapter
oh he's crap so basically the Boston of
North America okay thank you Thank You
ver there we go
ooh wait you could play the subway
playlet subway has play lands yeah
that's interesting I love it whoo Morgan
for Dragon Age Origins dirty Dexter why
is that why is Morgan front what am I
supposed to break this no I guess not
why are they the most well-adjusted
character I'm gonna say I mean Super
Mario is a pretty well-adjusted
character although there isn't there's
that crazy theory I don't know if you
guys remember there's this crazy theory
where Super Mario the only real one Oh
hey nice shades bro there's a theory
that one of you guys have heard this but
Super Mario is the only real game and
the other ones are all crazy fan jealous
fantasies Mario has been having what
because peach left him for Bowser yeah
oh my god oh my god what this is this
seems unfair
he's on shrooms though
good point tuxie good points bleh fierce
Conan because Conan is boss of bleh
cries himself to sleep conquer moves I
know you wrote that in all caps but
you're exactly right you're 100% correct
oh man maybe maybe they taught me to
dodge move because I'm supposed to be
dodging which I'm not doing at all
I might just suppose it Oh dive you
oh no he jumped away yeah Gingrich I
agree so Mario definitely self-medicates
you know one thing you don't see a lot
of video games are therapists and really
most most video game characters should
be in therapy this game is awesome I
have to say Oh
except when you get kicked in the head
you know what I'm not doing a good job
of he's getting Energon cubes okay why
does this guy just leave me alone I
don't understand his problem why do we
have a beef man Oh get him right in the
crotch
hashtag crotch hits oh man
[Music]
also I got a few robots here's my
picture the Decepticons if you're a
robot why would you turn into a human
like a human form a human floor is not
the the most you know what I'm saying
it's like a Pinocchio thing oh they just
but why do they but there's so much more
powerful than humans humans are a fairly
weak species don't don't take our form
we just evolved this way if you could
change in any form you know transform
into something cool you know like look
at what think about I guess there are
like insects though right in sectors
Grand Theft Auto 5 has a therapist and
you end up chewing it no oh that's
hilarious
oh there we go perfect oh yeah Gingras
it's the last get your right until dawn
had a therapist until dawn by the way
that great game with that hayden
Panettiere and rami malek mr. robot last
last night wha golden globes which is
awesome Christian Slater I think one and
the stroke that's drama miss robots
great but uh but yeah until dawn which
has rami malek and hayden Panettiere in
it yeah therapist
you end up murdering we played some
until dawn on here you're gonna hit it
with a link and with that link watch our
until dawn goodness
there's a spin-off at where they turn
into almost Li sized animals yeah you're
right I think at the end at the end of
the Transformers run they were just what
else can we turn into I'm surprised they
didn't get two appliances actually
I'm about to die
are there like some where's the health
oh here we go
give me there's an Energon cubes yeah I
like when the arrow points me towards
the big robot it's like hey he's over
here yeah did I get it
loving this vehicle attack no that's a
fun I opened this game you get to play
somebody else besides op
kind of like the Power Rangers too many
very Katie I agree I don't like yeah
there's too much just too much the one
of the Michael Bay movies had a vending
machine that shot
hands what hey you crave a
am i doing anything to this guy ever
tried using your item I know the answer
is No
what am i how do I use my Oh dodge him
oh you know what I should be dodging him
because that kind of freezes him
I got crushed dodging kind of freezes
ol3 and r3 maybe yeah you're right
alright well we're learning no no
there's not there's there's uh we have a
great photo gallery of summer
ride-alongs photos that will link to in
the comments yeah
next game are very excited taping it I'm
actually today they're bringing the game
that I'm supposed to be playing which is
gonna be very fun top secret but I think
you guys are gonna like it first gamer
of 2016 what do you guys want what guyot
what games do you guys want to see us
play for gamer this year besides I am
bread which by the way I downloaded
missed our plane
what's up Sony two men you can see
thanks for joining us
oh the reason says I played Magic the
Gathering Xbox was all right that'd be
fun I used to be so into Magic the
Gathering
I'd have blue in a white tank is nearly
I believe oh no no she's touching the
dragons and for recounting my old nerdy
things we're gonna be here all day
oh here's a more for could be fun until
Donna be ready what do you guys think
what are your thoughts unlike the new
kind of like there's a couple games that
are some fun storytelling you know we
could do like a roundup of all you know
like those games for you I don't want to
say choose-your-own-adventure but that's
basically what it is who x come also
overwatch is supposed to be good who's
played over if you guys play overwatch
yet anybody found some early over
watching Slater was awesome on Archer a
Street Fighter 5 Mass Effect Andromeda
Mass Effect is a game I have to get into
everybody says it's amazing but I got to
start from the beginning I think in each
one of those games is like 60 hours
right off the bat I get punched in the
brains how scripted food
a little insight yeah so I've said this
before but basically the deal is Conan
doesn't see the game until he sits down
in the room then the cameras are on so
he doesn't a lot of times he doesn't
know what game we're gonna play which is
putting your trust in me as a mistake
but it's worked out so far but uh but
yeah and basically we come up with Todd
and I Tod eleven when the writers on our
show and I will come up with things that
we think are funny like areas so I go
there's so many characters in this game
it'd be fun to see what Conan thought
thinks about the characters or will say
you know like for the WWE one we did wo
II like I made a Conan character I was
like this'll be great
he can have his own character that'll be
fun so we kind of come up with areas and
then Conan just eats Conan he says one
thing you eat Conan used to say a lot
which doesn't say so much anymore but
just like unshackle Kong let Kong run
free I know he even has actually a
someone made him an artist rendering of
him as King Kong breaking out of
shackles but that's the thing it's like
Conan is so smart and so funny and so
he's just very quick and so anything you
bring to him he makes better and funnier
which is like I'm very very lucky to
work for a person like that so you know
we just come up with areas and he goes
crazy and cut the stuff he finds in the
game are is amazing and like you know
one of my favorite examples is a lot of
times we'll find stuff that I didn't
even think would be funny he'll make
comedy out of it and the best example
which I said before is Tomb Raider with
Lara Croft where she keeps dying on the
river I was just like oh we're gonna go
down the river to get to this other area
I was like oh it'll be so fun to do that
I think parachuting or something I think
that'll be really funny but then she he
just he came up with his bit of falling
in love with Lara Croft and then when
she kept getting killed
it just was hilarious and so that was
you know that's what you always hope
will happen and does happen luckily
this gamer is it's he just finds things
that are really really funny so yeah so
that's basically how it goes but that's
also wide support when we choose
clueless gamer games that's why not
every game kind of works because you
need to kind of have enough different
areas in case he doesn't take the bait
on a certain area to which a lot of
times he doesn't take the bait on
fritzsche it's like I thought and
fallout 4 I was like oh I'll be great
you know we can make like we can really
make this characters face and you know
starve up its up and I didn't end up
being you know there's a little bit but
we didn't really take the bait on that
so we ended up finding a lot of other
funnier stuff wait after I die right now
probably won't still alive
MUFON says Tomb Raider then I played
that part and remember that bit yeah I
will say for anyone played who's played
that to murder at least it makes you
feel good about yourself that you're not
dying as many times as you like about a
week we cut like a minute and a half of
him dying on same thing with crossing
the streets and call of duty that took
us 45 minutes to cross the strip E but
that was something I was like okay we'll
cross the street and then do this fun
thing but then crossing the street just
became the funny bit out of that which
is great and that's like for me that's
one of the biggest joys of doing
clueless gamer is just seeing the game
through Conan's eyes is really really
fun
psychotic rage says you guys could
pretty much make anything work in hooks
little areas thank you that's being
generous but that's all Conan
I am the planks of which the food is set
upon and made funny
that's a weird analogy it shows how
hungry I am boy 84 95 says make Conan
play the most boring game ever what's
the most boring game me doing my taxes
what is the most boring game ever oh
what is that kid desert drive 20 desert
drive 1993 Desert Bus the legendary does
request sure
oh oh I can do that the whole time
[Music]
kill them I like firstly there is great
we played far silver I was not actually
boring it was actually a sealer later
lame sunglasses by the way oh hey
now I'm bumblebee who Reptar Nam says I
remember you guys did a special Atari
episode give you something like that so
that means from games that's a good call
I do want to do an indie game round oh
well look how fast an sounds good to me
where am I going
I guess this way whoa weird shower with
your dad simulator
I mean I'll play it hey hey there and
play what's up where the comb bone at
comb bone is yeah we're doing yeah we're
doing uh yeah we're doing it we're
taping somebody after the show I think
we're doing another extra interview
sometimes we do we sometimes we have to
take the show out of order we do things
we like to call cobblers Oh where we'll
cobble yeah yum yum yum or we'll cobble
the show together and so we're taping a
famous person after the show today so
we're taping a little bit earlier
is this look at this what do I want my
blasters come on I think this don't play
video game nope
Sona does not soda hates babies and me
wait wait hold on wait I'm not doing I'm
not doing this properly basic machine
gun
I guess I got to drive through this
when was the movie FBI my money yeah
that's never how I'm taking damage when
I do this wait question I can't not turn
into this car yo bro I'm getting railed
I'm getting totally destroyed oh now I'm
a guy how do I shoot those guys oh there
we go Oh
this game is really fun by the way Nalin
rainy or if you want you can interview
me okay they could have played Truck
Simulator 2 cuz he likes murica so much
who Slovakia Hegel imma go to bar delle
cose own is doing well she's doing real
well you know Sona she kicks it she's
kicking it like always
oh my shirt ESCO beats today says don't
flatter yourself I drunk text everybody
although it's me fair I rent a 45 person
party bus on Saturday night for my
birthday and didn't drunk text anybody
guys I behave myself aren't we proud of
me we're just so proud of me
short burst controlled center mass so
they do it
right in the Sun look if you're a robot
or not that's got to hurt the old eyes
woo this came this real fun
tell every 85 normally now okay on my
private stream I try to stream Wednesday
what's up here trust room Wednesday
Saturdays and Sundays but I've been so
busy with other things I haven't been I
haven't streamed at all the past couple
weeks I'm really gonna try to stream on
Friday night and we do he we do we do
little drinkie do little Streamy maybe
Friday and Sunday hopefully supposed to
be working on other things guys it's
it's tough it's tough by other things I
don't mean
having a girlfriend which I don't dirty
Dexter such a mean joke came to mind for
my party bus story then don't say it
2016 the year of not being mean don't be
mean to in 2016
how about that
20:16 don't be mean yeah take that giant
dumb thing
you've got a little cash a slansky no
III remotes we couldn't do it this year
we just couldn't put it together with
too uh too many other things going on
sorry Wednesday Friday and Sunday what
did I say
be mean in 2016 says right answer seven
baby maybe I need to be a little meaner
[Music]
another route this V I don't have the
power I need Wow oh god I mean this is
have a terrible Drive this is by the way
how I Drive it just doesn't we have a
good point though in Chicago and New
York the elevated train situation freaks
me out like I'm shocked that more people
don't run into those boys yeah shocked
or maybe a lot of people do uh Reptar
now did you get to chest me I am if the
cast of Star Wars The Force awakens I
got to meet a couple of those people III
got to meet Oscar Isaac before who by
the way best human being yet so handsome
so handsome I didn't get to be Harrison
Ford I said hi to Harrison Ford that
counts boy yay guy I said hi to I didn't
actually get to meet anybody so no is
the answer and that's a really dumb
question
Oh bb8 I met bb-8 that was cool what is
this thing though there's too much
traffic for people who run into them yes
exactly
yeah that's a good point
I guess in that way traffic helps I
think the annex will be released this
year is the annex the new Nintendo thing
flame beacon ah I think it will be
released this year I don't know what
it's gonna be though it's interesting
like the Wii U is awesome but I feel
like the game selection is more geared
weirdly towards I mean like multiplayer
couch co-op because now couch co-op it's
like going the way of the dodo by that I
mean it's becoming its extinct which is
kind of a bummer because I love couch
co-op and that's something that we deal
with here on Monday melee a lot is I'm
always looking for games to play couch
co-op and there's not a lot well look
how far in through that car this is
awesome
that's great bb-8 is that say for
bodybuilding 8 evil that says I don't
know no knows what it stands for
although my friend Ben Schwartz the
voice him is Bill Hader the voice of BB
a pretty great bar della they're gonna
reel EDX and ie 3 2016 there we go ride
z7 I have tried oculus rift it's amazing
we use more fun family-friendly and by
the way really fun Mexico beats we you
have some of the most fun games on the
market right now
Mario bro 42 Aaron who do you think is
the most annoying and most weird in the
Coco staff boo me for sure I'm
definitely the most annoying and
probably the weirdest I'm pretty weird
annoying dude I'm gonna be honest
2016 year of not being mean I'm being
honest doesn't count I don't count as a
person battlefront is couldn't couch
co-op no it doesn't by the way you're
wrong
hi Germany
what happened to beef can't go beef camp
you come back Smash Bros yes Smash Bros
is great killer Beeson let me going here
oh we have to find a new way acrost did
we do that
I guess we're supposed to go up here
it looks like we're supposed to get up
there somehow oh then maybe jump across
or something I gave the engineer by the
by couch co-op I mean like like four
player funds split-level action like
battlefronts okay but it's not like left
4 dead 2 was awesome you know like it's
that that stuff is great
like I love here we go Oh gang beasts
yeah gang beasts
Megatron what is the meaning of Optimus
to say I presume I am here to stop you
from destroying the city stop me no idea
what you're really up against do you who
is really behind this this is our home
now Megatron we should respect it grindy
games like Borderlands yeah blow
interested destroy creeper to the rescue
Squasher says and he's the minecraft
creeper that was great
I wanted to get that tattoo of mouse on
your face rush attack max speed and use
a melee attack
[Applause]
oh whoops
how do I know what top speed is
oh whoops I didn't wrong button
Oh in your face meg oh I just caught
megatron meg to weigh less hey Meg oh
right in the crotch or ooh ooh that's
got to hurt
I'm kicking him like in the crotch from
like 50 miles an hour and the way it
moves is kind of very rocket League s
boom Conan was extremely frustrated over
oculi because it was a video game I
loved Optimus Prime is just standing
there
you take care of Megatron my arch enemy
bumblebee even though you're the
smallest of the Transformers yeah here
we go here we go boy yeah man oh my god
this is awesome I just this dude's
crotch better have a lot of armor on it
hashtag crotch armor
[Applause]
that's the kid is true that is true I
don't know that's a good thing though I
think you want to be somewhere in the
middle oh man I am just destroying
Megatron's crotch right now
uh I know it it's a good question
I know you play he's played Minecraft on
his own favorite camis playtest up I
know he like The Witcher 3 a lot he left
ton the Tony Hawk game he had a good
time playing with Tony a little way yeah
that was great
Lil Wayne coolest dude ever brother
nicest guy
[Applause]
ah do you like punching people do you
like it when I punch Megatron the crotch
or kick him in the crotch oh you do kick
in the crotch
I need some of those green Energon cubes
dude by the way Optimus thanks for just
standing there you freaking dick
I have no life left it's why huh I don't
think so
uh-oh he might have been yeah 93
probably was where did that question
come from yeah give us give us your
reasoning oh no it's the final episode
of 1990 no no overlap
got it don't it seems like any game
where you can get laid baby that's true
conan is partially getting late in games
Skyrim II like because you've killed a
bunch of chickens hey hey hey there and
bleh yell play would you rather be back
in NY we miss Coco yeah I wish to be on
both coasts or Austin be fun to be in a
hostage or Boston Boston let's just dial
it back it's a good city boy says have
my shirt says don't flatter yourself
I don't text everybody booze - Beth of
you got a drug tax for me ever maybe
during like a road show like where you
at everyone yeah that's that road shows
are yours you were sending me attack of
3 p.m. road show it a failure Jesus
alright it's kind of harsh yeah road
shows are everyone's drunk texting
everyone all the time during the day
during the show Who am I now I'm like
Optimus oh look at this little car
[Music]
I love this animation I wish more games
were like this alright come to South by
Southwest quasar I've been there before
I'll go again with this a-hole just
sitting here mmm this looks like a tough
bug going to beat that jerkface
alright let's go the reason I had that
oh the elf things because Conan looked
like out Touche I mean I guess how what
am I supposed to do here who decide
chili balls us whose is Optimus Prime
drunk text like random fax machines he's
met my little hussy fax machine hey what
are you doing later I got some facts for
you
voices you didn't finish me in my chat
I'm sideswipe I don't know what that
means derp in productions but I love
derp in productions so I can't get
through here what am I supposed to do
here get up here we go up
turn into a car and feed at that then
punch it Oh got it thank you yeah thank
you for saving us 20 minutes and me
battering of this thing
gee Beth says fax machine optimises into
gilfs what's a grandma uh no he liked
the optimist probably likes older ladies
offers many ways thousands of years old
yeah people don't realize he's not a
shiny new piece of technology he's old
so yeah he'd be into PT B and unlike
machines his age yeah
which i think is appropriate yeah you
shouldn't be like hooking up with like
smartphones
that's like inappropriate you know
yeah that's robbing the cradle dude
that's not good gross here oh yeah Joe
drop kick man I wish I could dropkick
people it'd be so fun I just drop kick
people all day here's a probably drop
kick you fall down on the ground and
hurt yourself
yeah how do you not hurt yourself and
drop kicking anybody know I need drop
kick experts out there in the chat
please let us know awesome right
birthday college roommate Tom crow gave
me this awesome boba fett Nixon watch
look at this thing perks with Nixon
pretty great boba fett watch there has a
little picture of Boba Fett on the back
to show you hold on I'm gonna get
murdered well the fact there you got a
little picture of Boba Fett on the back
and I need to see it pretty dope oh now
I'm gonna get murdered why don't people
our people have so accessible I have
swords game on why are people so
obsessed with Boba Fett he was only in
the movies for a short period of time
coolest helmet in the game probably
and this do you do they vehicle attack
that's been saving me
oh yeah oh that's yeah then you're still
you're like hurt your ribs whoa who's a
former pro wrestler cuz bummer fellas
cool you're right 2% milk that's exactly
why it's just so cool
oh man scheme is I gotta say this camp
is really fun
not just cuz it I'm a sword-wielding
giant robot but the combat is pretty
great
I wish I knew a block was
when do my sweet vehicle attack on this
mofo where's he at where's he at
oh yeah I just love your like a car
doing donuts like smashing into
something Oh got him boom not gonna be
the Cassidy Star Wars movie no although
I could pass for a Tuscan Raider I think
though they say love Arkham Knight loved
the other Arkham games i never played
arkham origins but the other ones were
super fun Batman I love that flow combat
I love like jumping into 50 dudes and
just like drop kicks so wait as doing a
drop kick you like you jump and you do
this and then you like flip around it's
like this and then you like how does
that work
I still think falling on your stomach is
gonna hurt ya are your side I think
that's what I didn't understand like
you're cycling yeah kind of this isn't
me jump kicking that's head lakers
two-bath 16 this is transformers
devastation this game is great really
fun by the way and i like playing games
that not a lot of people oh here we go
get me up in there maybe you haven't
heard of transformers devastation but
maybe you should maybe it's fun I love
jumping into 50 and I mean it in every
way possibly jumping into it dude pit
kill the sick man ah the man pit that's
right we made when we yeah what am I
supposed to do toss down I would I never
pay attention in these games I want to
go through these here
more enemy combatants Oh innatron
serious
Wow I got killed quickly Stinger Splash
as unless you talked about game that's
why I can't wait for PlatinumGames to
make their team yeah exactly
Segura this is a jewel of a game nobody
played filled with masculinity exactly
back to the back to the man pit the man
pile the mitt follow Megatron to the
steel tower okay last game I finish
that's my played was fallout 4 never
finished it
little a scheme I finished was it's a
great question I'm gonna have to go with
it so a scheme I finished I'll try
asking my Finnish would be
I missed him
finished it's a smaller Oh probably
what's that game it was an Xbox Live
Arcade game I may miss on PlayStation it
was reissue you like run around guys
help me out there was like a voiceover
guy and it was like the earth it was
like after the earth had been kind of
destroyed I did a lot of twitching with
it
Jesus Christ
you have like a sword and you can also
have a cannon Bastion that's what it was
yeah that was the last gaming finish
very fun whoo I don't get to finish a
lot of games because I don't a lot of
time and then a lot of games kind of
don't I'm kind of out for these I'm over
the part of my life where I need to like
finish a book if it sucks or I need to
like finish a game if I'm not enjoying
either stop playing it plus males way
easier way easier to live your life that
way
whoo I'm going way too fast
State can't see where I'm going perfect
nailed it
railing this dude
kind you a double vehicle attacker no
nope
I love triumphs but no way I don't want
to be made fun of
yeah railing this dude guys free love
you know doesn't matter who you make
love to as long as you're making love
you know 2016 I don't know rail dudes
2016 rail 16 dudes not three games of
the moment oh man top three games the
moment that's tough um this game how
three games at the moment I mean the
games I'm playing our alien isolation
which is great although I'm kind of in a
slow part and fallout 4 which is okay
very shooty and I don't know what keeps
my playing kind of between games right
now I'm looking for a game to play
do you like drink
ooh there's a little actually no game
I'm playing a lot on my phone is a
hearthstone Idol playing it's pretty fun
my mom got me into this cooking game
that I'm really into Mary Blair loves
this cooking cooking time which I played
a lot lately it's so hard to get the hot
dogs how long do you have right now I'm
reading misery I'm about halfway through
misery it's great I've never read seen
kings miss awesome what's happened okay
I feel like horrible Avery misery over
break I read
that sucks never played candy crush oh I
tried to take candy crush off my phone
too addicting
yeah oh Jesus what's this any look I
made it through that's pretty good and
auto repair kit so do these guys go to a
hospital or a mechanic oh wait I just
did a double crazy attack yeah yeah like
a poke they go to a Pokemon Hospital
yeah you're right oh come on this guy
again I don't need to know it what is it
called nope nope don't need to fight
hard
whoa this looks dangerous they go to the
zone the AutoZone they go to the vet
I haven't played transistor what's
transistor totally read alibi hmm oh
it's just part of the success discrete
games is from Vladimir boats all right
well not just crazy double crazy eyes in
the matrix ah neo you come back to a
live person game's hot pan there are
some games that come back to you but I
don't know if they're games that people
would enjoy games like wait am I
supposed to be breaking these things
like left for dead - I've come back - a
lot
what else would I come back - a lot
oh really
I'll have to check it out cuz yeah I
really like fasting a lot I thought was
super fun it was a fun game cuz it got
really intense at parts but then it
wasn't so intense that you're just like
it made you crazy am I supposed to be
fighting this dude or what's up I
supposed to be following him
I fight this am i fighting baguette
router just following Megatron do we
have any idea am I supposed to beat in
there am i racing him I can't really get
in front of them that's the case
returned
I mean I'm on his I'm on his ass
oh I see are two so she's firing out of
this whole time don't I feel like a goof
ow
I see it's much harder when you have to
fire out of it
where is he
Megatron I can't look at the maps to
insane Jesus Christ this is crazy
where is your boy Megatron at you know
what his back has to be having that gun
on one hand one arm that's got to be bad
for his back yeah really yeah I mean
that can't be more dying I don't know
man I've died quite a bit you sure you
want more of this dying
Jesus
[Music]
do you want more dine you got it cuz I'm
about to die Jesus Lord
[Music]
Oh
give me that vehicle attack give me that
vehicle attack okay
[Music]
whoo that hurt him a lot wow that really
hurt him so now we have his energy Jesus
Wow well he took that home anergy dodge
should be my best friend got it tanker
you'll play between you and cone and
who's more pale air Oh Conan for sure
Conan's like clear they have to put a
they have to put make up on some people
can see him kind of like hop out of you
guys have ever seen the movie Holloman
but that's basically Conan
Oh
where's the code in math good question I
missed him
[Music]
all right keeping the face by robot
I must say the Michael Bay robots Oh
Michael Michael Bay transformers are
kind of hard to look at you know like oh
there we go there we go that sucks sorry
it says don't flatter yourself I drunk
text everybody
which is true I do notoriously
[Music]
yeah gonna put that Instagram F this I
don't have my double thing give me the
double thing bro wear them Energon cubes
act oh I missed him oh my god I missed
him nope you missed him
god it's too
that that I'm dead I'm dead day-o
Raptor nom I was invited Jordans wedding
but I couldn't go unfortunately I had
something else happening that day
hey blast man 13 thank you for hosting
us it's very nice of you
I love it who's legal bot Oh bot no CY
is an optimist doing this you know what
I'm saying
Oh am i up no I'm not optimistic
optimist not prime uh I have a special
part of my floor I keep all my clothes
on the floor in my floor drug here's
what we're gonna try we're gonna try a
new thing where we only do the two the
two while I'm gonna destroy right now
where we only do the attack and then the
special move let's try that
[Applause]
when I hit the side I think that hurts
me too
[Music]
so we're gonna like me
I'm just sticking move man stick and
move baby I know who said that VAR dalla
stick and move to get around and let's
get around and let's get around and okay
oh I see if I hit the side thing it also
hurts oh my god I'm just barely touching
him but that I think he it's the side
thing it kind of hurts him right
whenever we had a favorite Oh
favorite nes game is tough I really like
double dribble I know that's boring
I gotta get back into the nes man so
many classes
get Ellen on dirt I think Hillary is it
Ellen Oh is there
that's not why there's that's why they
will availability go hug attacker it's
her
I need life how do I get born life
when was that last night basically fun
Dula explain the dream if you're hit if
it's graphic yourself weird movies yeah
are you like are you pregnant in the
email dream emails what's an email do I
like have a dream that DS no math I mean
email when I wake up to fix it check the
emails that you go not there's a
nightmare I had about that's a pretty
tame nightmare though I the nightmare I
had a nightmare that uh snakes with with
antennas for eyes and huge mouths and
bat wings on their heads came and tried
to bite my feet yeah I don't know German
productions I don't know why all the
Autobots aren't fighting Megatron at
once that what are they doing just
hanging out I'm eating hummus or
whatever Autobots yeah just like that
fresh vegetables and pita bread and
stuff oh I wouldn't tell anybody there's
a great reddit thread by the way about
what to do if you win the lottery
everybody should read it and it's
basically like sign the ticket first of
all then get like contact a financial
advisor first before you tell anyone
else then like cash the ticket but then
like have a plan I'm part of that part
of that plan by the way is which is
actually kind of cool like set up a
trust for like all your family members
and give them all whatever you want to
give them 20 grand 100 grand whatever
and then say this is all you're going to
get from the ever you know and then it's
like that's it so you're then you're
you're setting up a good precedent
then ask you for money it's like no I've
already given you everything and there's
also like other things like charitable
you know whatever yeah but uh but having
like a plan and also like a thing of
don't reveal your identity if you don't
have to you because there are some
states where you don't have to reveal
your identity sou you have a year by the
way to cash it adds say 1.3 billion yeah
like after taxes you really are gonna
get like like it's not it's so nothing
basic like what can you even do with
this nothing you can't do why but I was
like I don't know that I would really
change my life that much I mean this is
crazy but I really enjoy working here
yeah and I'd buy my mom like a big house
out here for sure and then I don't know
that I would do much dinner I don't even
know if I'd move apartments honestly I
really like my apartment I mean I know
it's got crickets and stuff in it but
but you know it's like the kind of thing
of like I think it's important to not go
crazy immediately because it's like you
know I think I make sure my family's
taken care of first and then
anymore combos going
[Music]
but I definitely continue working here
at least for a while
I don't think I telling you that you
feel like at maybe ever here you know
what I would do though kill I pay
someone to beat this game this guy
build a giant wardrobe yeah building
what's the first thing everybody would
buy yeah
tanker mm decal is that many big words
over to change their way alive I think
that the secret is to not really change
you know what I would do though one
thing that I don't do now is I would
invest in some sort of bar or restaurant
I'd like to partially own of something
very small like very very small but just
that that would be cool like that would
be a cool thing yes you opening a book
store like something I wouldn't want to
run either those things but it'd be cool
to like have some kind of a business
like that that then you don't have to
worry about so much about like it being
super stressful because you don't run it
yeah but I'd like to have a band then my
friends could play like their bands
could play in there and stuff but
something very very small well I read
that if you haven't read and live from
Saturday night the oral history of
Sarnia live great great book highly
highly recommend and actually a lot of
people including Conan Paula Davis who's
our head talent Booker and Jim Pitts
who's our music Booker are all in in
that book but one thing is like they
like I think Dan Aykroyd and John
Belushi had like a little tiny bar and
like David Bowie played there like a
bunch of people would play there and
that I thought I think would be super
fun to own just something like I really
like hole in the wall
[Applause]
we're fielding free onion rings forever
open a coffee shop and save money no
someone said they would buy your whole
family hungry your family oh that's very
nice then I would fight your family a
house too yeah all right Pete David
Bowie by the way Gabe the engineer says
I figure I need 3.5 million to live the
same way I do not forever so I'd only
keep about that much for this yeah
exactly I mean yeah right I would be
smart with it I'm not gonna be crazy
who's on the show tonight captive quasar
ass got our boy Jack McBrayer Oh Oh Neil
deGrasse Tyson which is huge I'm very
excited how excited to you for Neil
deGrasse Tyson well you know we saw him
in the airport O'Malley and I saw him in
real life he's huge by the way yeah
there's a crazy photo I don't know if
we're allowed to broadcast it but of him
as a wrestler when he's younger he's
ripped by the way it's awesome you ever
seen that photo no oh my god it's
amazing because he's like one of the
smartest people and he was like super
rift it's crazy
put into bad
but even more like dodging I think
[Applause]
where can with someone get the volcano I
don't think they they made them for us
I think there are the only Huey that's
true they took my measurements and made
it skin tight for me oh there's that
yeah there's a link to ripped Neil
deGrasse Tyson it's awesome
epi set one says maybe try some cheats
to beat the boss go to UT so another
plus for Austin there you go someone's
been there a hundred million for cloning
the other grad thing that'd be pretty
great although I don't think there's no
guarantee he would be as smart as Neil
deGrasse Tyson or she I put a lot of
money into I believe in mental health so
I put a lot of money into mental health
and into education I think yeah what
like charities
yeah those two things I think cuz I
think a lot of I will say I think a lot
of Oh
yeah you gotta give I really like the
Warren Buffett Bill Gates thing of them
giving away a lot of their money to
charity that's that's what it counts in
the end man up another people
this isn't doing it our strategy here
[Music]
I just need to be more aggressive and
not give them like so much of a time to
wind up
he does that thing on me it's bad
get it
there we go they're all now we're
talking now we got ourselves a card game
[Music]
got it boom Sammy I'm what's next like
close camera can't tell you bro it's
exciting though MD said if I won I'd
bring Stargate sg-1 back well I'd bring
MacGyver back MacGyver and quantumly for
two huge shows I love one bow ah Columbo
my friend RJ White has a Columbo podcast
called just one more thing that's less I
was on it once and I said how much I
hated Columbo and he got so much I got
so much hate mail from that there's a
lot of really really really passionate
Columbo fans I think I'm not a fan of
Columbo I don't like Columbo box too
slowly paced I don't like the whole I
don't like the whole you find out you
know what watch an episode of television
I don't care about that beautiful I
don't care
and by the way I do you like longer
shows like what's this a plague activate
it all right uh I do like like the Dick
Cavett show like I like these longer
shows but Columbo
I just doesn't do it for me man it's
just boring no Pierre Fogg was a prick
yeah ooh what do we want here you leave
Peter Falk alive you leave Peter Falk
alone wait what do I have anything that
I can use here what am I supposed to be
doing here the cryo hammer
[Music]
mother did he ever leave home no he
never did
oh cool now we can switch characters no
he never leave Tom that was so sad I
wept at the end of quantum leave he
never turned home the last thing he did
was help out his best best friend al
that was it but he elite who I could
change warriors now at watch while that
sounds great
I'd love toys I'm gonna be Optimus why
would you want to be anybody but Optimus
the joy of painting back but Bob Ross is
dead or x-files but it's already funny
back at the start thanks Pete
that's what oh yeah x-files is back with
our pal kimitaka male not Jenny here we
go we're entering the arc he or I do
need to know the way of the transformers
please teach me
why don't attack us
I get a new fellas thank you yeah there
we go
[Music]
really I'd rather be the smoking man or
no I'd rather be the weird black goo but
so what was the point of x-files it was
these two what the idea was it was these
two alien races that had come to earth
and that we're fighting secretly like
the alex krycek and those guys right if
you dig it all and he scratched the
surface but apparently they're like what
was like Project Paperclip and all that
stuff
marah's like Project Paperclip was like
they clone no they were late
we're like using alien technology to do
what to do evil stuff she wasn't really
that's what happens man American TV
shows too many freaking episodes kill
them yeah slut-shaming this game is
awesome
big fans cel-shading they should use it
more I don't know what it takes I feel
like it's probably in some ways takes up
less you know what I'm saying like less
what am I trying to say
less coding papads you do some really
cool cell shading things what am I
talking about I lost my mind
oh god please I just need hey come on
dude they are hardly bringing Twin Peaks
back David Bowie was in Twin Peaks
welcome me yeah oh it's great he's the
first agent they send out who disappears
who gets taken by the Black Lodge in the
movie yeah he's the first agent they
send out before what's-his-face there's
a great moment where and David Lynch I
think is one of the aged is one of the
people 208 in the movie I know he's not
the first agent ya know but I think the
movie thing takes place he's like a
pretty cool yes yeah yeah but he who
Chris Isaak is the first agent right
David Bowie's in their summer who does
David Bowie play in firewalker
cuz he does play somebody there's a
really great creep there's a really
great creepy moment in the movie where
there's they're in this police station
and it's Stephen Lynch I think and he
keeps saying he's like no no he's like
there's something wrong here there
something wrong and he goes and he keeps
running back on camera I think he'll run
like back to where
the thing is and he's like no no it's
that you don't understand like it
doesn't it was it's weird and at one
point he runs back and then he runs to
look at that what's on the TV and then
you see like David Bowie's they're
frozen weirdly or something it's super
it's really creepy and awesome I just
like yeah that's awesome that's great
ha ha
save me I read he doesn't have by Aaron
blade you played yourself DJ please I
gotta follow DJ clean up snapchat
apparently he's the man we saw that
spongebob taking with it David Bowie
boys
[Applause]
interesting question someone asked about
the difference big differences between
building
New York is tough because it's hard to
make things in New York not look like
they're in New York you know New York is
a is a city and is it's a very you know
it's not like Vancouver which is by the
way there's a great a YouTube web series
called every frame of painting which is
going if everything's and they have this
great episode on how Vancouver never
gets to play itself it plays everybody
else but New York it's hard to do that
so that's one of that that's a tough
part about shooting in New York also you
know you don't have a lot of space in
Newark
however you do have a lot of people in
New York and so in that way it's all
it's always easy to like go out and do
things on the street with people because
you know they're just walking around
whereas like here you have to go if you
want to do like a man on the street
thing you have to go somewhere to like
city WA you know someplace where there's
a lot of people so that's kind of it
that kind of informs the comedy a little
bit differently you know it's hard to
shoot stuff on the street in New York
it's hard to do so so it's just
different challenges and here you know
we're on a lot so we can do you know we
can have we can go to easily go to a
quote unquote neighborhood and shoot
something in a normal house whereas like
in New York we had to go to like New
Jersey you know which is then you're
factoring in time across the bridge and
like you know it just takes a lot longer
to shoot it
now you actually really don't have to do
better than okay good to know
sombras I beat portal 2 it's awesome
portal 2 is one of my favourite games of
all time well they're not great for a
gamer because it's already really funny
it's hard to do a gamer on games yeah
like we were gonna do a gamer on a game
but it just ended up being too funny and
then we did WWE instead
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you you're welcome
man he says is he's getting his butt
kicked
I don't make new year's resolutions guys
I don't do it why why it's just
something you're gonna break also every
day guess what every day happens once a
year you can make a resolution
resolution any time my resolution of the
be more mean in 2016 is that wait what
is the RISM is it be less me sorry be
less mean in 2016
[Music]
no damn it
ah can one of them be dead no don't
return to the ark can one of them be
dead no please
I'm gonna give this one more shot
ah News resolutions what's up words new
year's resolution I'm already in shape
so I don't work out less we're Cutlass
I'm gonna have somebody carry me around
so I have to walk more bagels more carbs
in 2016
stop eating clean in 2016 visa oh that's
pretty good anymore being a pretty party
though that's a dangerous resolution the
nipple rub is a new thing I like it
[Music]
oh wait I have this I haven't been using
my long-range weapon but can we just
shooting the crap I like that come on no
not fair
[Music]
negative 2017 is really the only
resolution we all should be thinking of
buy a house and find a girlfriend there
you go Jesus work out at least once
before the years over I carry with my
brain I like that idea
love that yeah
[Applause]
my new year's resolution is to be more
positive how about that pain train that
seems like a good resolution damn it
they're just destroying me
beat these guys in 2016 all right that's
it
I give up that's good it's over I can't
beat these two guys I'm stronger than
Hulk that's not true I'm more
emotionally stronger than Hulk
Oh guys thank you for joining us for
stream Coco Monday Meili today we were
playing transformers I keep wanting to
say terminator devastation but it's
transformers devastation and it was
awesome I think you saw us Beth Morosky
and the chat chaser Malik creeper in the
corner we'll see you guys next Monday
you